hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of Game of Thrones season 7
episode 3 the Queen's Justice an episode
that showed us if Cersei Lannister is
ever wearing lipstick something is very
very wrong now there is a lot to
breakdown stuff you missed subtle
connections to the books and past
episodes but also this time we're going
to include some bonus sections that take
harder in-depth looks at how this
episode uses things like shot imagery
scenes costuming and the history that
inspired all these characters and sure a
batch hit theory or two let's get
started okay so this episode opens with
waves crashing on the rocks of
Dragonstone now this is similar to last
episode which showed us the same stormy
waves at nighttime but now that the
storm has subsided these waves are
washing up some bad news for the nearest
one the news of your on defeating her
fleet and to the news brought by Jon
Snow that the army of the Dead will make
all of her lifelong ambition pretty
pointless now once we get on the beach
we get this longtime reunion between Jon
and Tyrion and notice how John
recognizes perience car picks up some
scarring on the road been a long road
now like many of you I was surprised at
how civil and reasonable all these guys
were I think it's because all three of
them have these kind of battle scars
from the wars that led them to this
point Tyrion and Davos have scars in the
Battle of Blackwater which they bring up
and John has scars from the battle the
bastards that led him to becoming Lord
of Winterfell and yeah obviously John
has a few other scars that were given to
him by the Nights Watch when he died but
he doesn't really want to bring those up
and I'll get to why later anyway I think
the idea is that all of these scars are
giving these War veterans a usual
respect for each other something that
they didn't have before and moving on to
two characters who have no respect for
each other's Varys and Melisandre so I
think a lot of people are wondering why
barracks is so hostile in the scene it
helps to look at these two as rival
advisors to the crown with different
sources of power Varys has secrecy and
rumors and informants and Melisandre has
mysticism and divine power it's kind of
like the head of the CIA versus Miss
Cleo
she's not around anymore just saying but
really there is actually already told us
exactly why he hates Melisandre way back
in season 3 remember he told hearing a
story of how he became a eunuch as a boy
he was castrated by a sorcerer who
chanted incantations he burned my parts
in a brazier the flames turned blue and
I heard a voice answer his call I dream
of the voice from the flames was it a
god a demon a conjurors trick I don't
know but the sorcerer called and a voice
answered and ever since that day I have
hated magic and all those who practice
and that scene is white so interesting
when Melisandre wins the conversation
with this line my lady I have to die in
this strange country just like you so I
think it's possible that the voice Varys
heard in those flames the voice that
haunt after all these years was the same
power that the Hound actually just saw
in the plane the Lord of life telling
Varys how he will die but while we're
talking about this
I think Melisandre's line is also
reminiscent of another moment in season
3 the moment she met Arya I see you
talking to you we will need again ok
moving on to the dragon stone throne
room with Jon Snow and Daenerys
Targaryen together at last
and even though the dialogue between the
two is very interesting I would say
their costumes alone tell the full story
between these two monarchs so let's go
into this and go into our Game of
Thrones fashion roundup ok so first up
we got Daenerys notice how she's wearing
this change now the costume designer
Michelle clapping said this chain is
meant as a lesser version of a crown and
she's never been fully coordinated on
the show so Clapton gave her this chain
to reflect her eagerness to get that
crown to acquire the Iron Throne and she
tries to do that by impressing her power
over John now let's look at John costume
for the first time this season we're
seeing him without his cape and furs and
that's because the designer wanted John
to look smaller and more vulnerable in
this scene actually later this episode
John puts his cape and furs back on and
while he looked less vulnerable he does
transform into a version of Ned Stark
Tyrion actually calls him a northern
fool just like how Ned Stark felt when
he was in King's Landing so really when
you look at their costumes together
compared to Daenerys who looms large in
the frame John looks like a small man
just standing in a small room and on one
side we have an eager almost queen
frustrated with the other side the
smaller strange northerner who devisor
ok coming out of our costume section you
may remember in the previous athena
Melisandre said that's why I've brought
eyes inside together of course that's a
nod to the title of the book series but
I also like how both Ice and Fire
applies to John and Daenerys is demeanor
in the scene there is firey in the way
she's trying to engage John and debate
and accuse him of disrespect and wasting
her time while John is cold as ice
willing to sack
fights the love between him and Danny I
I made it work really he is cold
shouldering this whole discussion if
he's not going to get any help to fight
the white walkers but then notice how
things soften between them when demerit
apologized for the actions of her father
the Mad King and I ask you not to judge
a daughter by the sins of her father and
of course the reason this melts John's
icy art if only for a second is this is
the same exact words Jon just used to
pardon the children of his former
enemies in the season premiere but I
will not punish a son for his father's
sins okay so big question here why
doesn't John won Davos to bring up his
resurrection by Melisandre well there's
a few ways to look at it but notice how
he initially described the White Walkers
the army of the Dead is on the motto for
one John realized that he already sounds
crazy enough trying to convince Daenerys
that White Walkers even exist and then
on top of that if he says hey I was also
brought back to life he sounds legit
crazy but another way of looking at this
is Daenerys already sees John as an
enemy to the north so if he reveals
himself as a supernatural being brought
back from the dead he's probably
concerned that Daenerys won't
discriminate between this dead person in
front of her and the army of the Dead
that he's trying to prepare to fight
okay moving on past Seon being picked up
by his fellow Greyjoy's to King's
Landing where you're on returns with a
hero's welcome and noticed how he rides
this horse which by the way has it's
awesome you're on crack and mask and he
rides his horse right into the red keep
this move actually mirrors another time
a hero of King's Landing rode a horse
into the red peak remember Tywin
Lannister after he rescued the city in
the Battle of Blackwater so I think
you're on is intentionally trying to
evoke Circe's father here this is
another one of his weird aggressive
flirt he's trying to be the bad boy
who's also just like dad
which is what every woman wants right
that's um that's what I read in those
books that haven't done anything for me
and notice what you're on says here I
give you what no other man could give
justice so of course the Queen's justice
is the title this episode and I'll
explain later what exactly it means and
how connects to these themes for this
episode I think it's also interesting
that Cersei set up this rivalry between
Jaime who leads two crowns army and
you're on who leads the Crown's Navy
it's kind of like how in real life there
has been famously a rivalry between the
branches of the armed forces alright
moving on to the crypts and right away
you probably notice that Cersei is
certainly wearing lipstick here which
isn't usual fur but of course by the end
of the scene is clear why but notice how
for just a moment Cersei actually lets
her guard down when talking about what
olaria did to her daughter Marcella and
you talk to me why did you do that so
this is real vulnerable emotion from
Cersei and the reason she has this
moment is we need to have just enough
sympathy for her so that when we see her
cruelly punish them this seems at least
a little justified actually I want to
give a shout-out to @vo Burk for
bringing the star attention the word
thirsty uses to describe what will
happen at ie might sound familiar
you will watch your drama there was that
beautiful this is they call back to last
season when Cersei was grieving
merciless death and she used this stage
imagery to describe how she feared her
daughter was rotting in the crypt
beautifully to say stuff and in case any
of you were wondering if ilaria might be
able to make a big escape actress Indira
Varma did say that this was her last
episode and as the light of the seven
violin music plays Cersei continues this
power streak by moving on to Jamie
notice how he's initially resistant but
Cersei pressures him into it anyway
and I think this is Cersei turning the
tables on Jaime from that super messed
up moment in season 4 when the memory of
another dead child of theirs led to a
similar situation now who is this short
haired made of Cersei this is actually
Bernadette she's been the same red keep
made since really the beginning of a
series you may remember as the
who discovered Santa's first period in
season two she's the one that Shay
threatened when she tried to go run tell
Cersei we also saw her bring Tyrion to
Santa in season three and then it sees
before she ratted out Shae interrupting
Cersei and Jaime fighting and then last
season she's the one who told Cersei
about Jaime's returned from Dorne and
she's the one who helps her to get ready
for the green trial so why now does she
have this short haircut actually think
this is evidence of Cersei starting a
new fashion trend all of her maids are
now trying to embody her look kind of
like in the 60s when Jackie Kennedy was
first lady everyone wanted to have her
hair cut okay moving on to this scene
with Cersei and Keiko Nestorius aka
Mycroft Holmes from Sherlock he's
representative of the iron bank now
notice how Tyco refuses this glass of
wine that Cersei offers now he reveals
moments later that he knows that it was
searching who flew off the set and it
wasn't an accident as she claimed so
yeah it makes sense that he's not going
to trust any food that Miss Queen
handsome now the iron bank actually has
roots in real world history so let's
dive deep into the historical influences
for this episode so we know george RR
martin based Game of Thrones
on the War of the Roses of England when
the houses of York and Lancaster which
might sound a lot like Stark and
Lannister these two houses battled over
the throne for decades but while that
war raged on in Italy there was the
Medici family they were one of the
richest and most powerful families of
Europe and they established a bank that
they use to fund different sides of this
war based off of whoever seemed like
they were most likely to win so the iron
bank is based on this medica Bank
notice how Tyco approves that Cersei
destroyed the religious forces of King's
Landing calling them to position the
ioan Bank appreciates how you cast off
the yoke of superstition there was
actually a rivalry between the medica
bank and the Catholic Church they were
the two most powerful forces in
Renaissance Italy and they both were
constantly jockeying for more influence
but eventually bidding on the wrong
sides of the War of the Roses doomed the
Medici bank and I predicts the same
thing will happen to the game of Thrones
iron bank okay coming out of this
history did notice how thirsty promises
to
Haizi iron bank set within a fortnight
and remember back in the season premiere
Jamie told her that the Tyrells of
Highgarden were now the richest family
of Westeros and now right after she has
given in to Jamie I think this all means
she signaled her next move okay moving
on
Tyrion ends up being the MVP of this
episode
he uses his negotiation skills to bring
John and Daenerys together and it's this
moment when Daenerys called them out for
quoting himself are you trying to
present your own statements as ancient
wisdom never do that to you so this is a
callback to the scene from last season
when Tyrion tried to make conversation
with Musante and grey worm in Mereen
wise man once said the true history of
the world is a history of great
conversations in elegant rooms he said
this me just now and then later when the
matchmaking his completes and John and
Daenerys come to terms I was interested
in genera some wine when she brings up
her brothers as there is regular he lost
two brothers as well so John used to
think that he lost three brothers right
Rob Rickon and brands but then last
season when Rickon returned to him well
almost
actually that letter from Ramsay
confirmed that the two boys weren't
burned by fee on that Rickon was still
alive and so brand must still be out
there - what really interested me about
the scene and something that's been
happening throughout this episode if
you've been paying attention is the
specific moments that parallel John with
his real-life birth father
Daenerys his brother Rhaegar Targaryen
so let's dive into this okay so first
earlier in this episode there was this
little moment back at Dragonstone but
I'm not a stock
so at the precise moment that John
distanced himself from his dark lineage
a dragon the symbol the Targaryen family
drops in the next moment came in the
scene that came after Davos says that
all those hard sons of [__] chose him
as their leader because they believed in
him this is actually a call back to
something Barristan Selmy told Daenerys
about Rhaegar in season three when your
brother Rhaegar led his army at the
Battle of the Trident men died for him
because they believed in a Linda and
then finally in this pain there's an
exchange between Daenerys and John I
want to enjoy what we're good at
I don't I think John is hinting that
he's good at killing
he just doesn't enjoy it and back in
season five there was another
conversation between Selmy and Daenerys
again about Rhaegar God never liked
killing so just to put this all together
this episode paints John as having this
connection with dragons a man who
inspires all of his men and a great
killer who doesn't like killing John
truly is his father's son okay moving on
to Winterfell and we get this very
interesting quote from Littlefinger that
it's actually stop to listen before
don't frighten them off on the South
tried every battle
everywhere always in your mind everyone
is your enemy everyone is your friend
every possible series of events is
happening all at once so Littlefinger is
advising Sansa to consider every
eventuality the way one might in a game
of chess but this is also how the
military played war games during the
cold war with experts simultaneously
thinking through every possible outcome
so that nothing could surprise them
actually if you were looking closely we
just saw Littlefinger considering one
eventualities in the previous scene so
watch Littlefinger when Warren talks
about the archives of Winterfell I'll
check mr. Lewin's Rexel chief kept a
copy of every raven scroll boom
Littlefinger is sharply and focused in
the shot and we're definitely meant to
notice him registering this information
I think this is Littlefinger realizing
that lewin kept records of every
correspondence in and out of Winterfell
meaning every letter that Ned and
catland received so what does it mean
maybe Littlefinger is afraid that
there's a paper trail that could be used
against him in some way or maybe he's
seen this as a possible treasure trove
of Winterfell secrets that he can delve
into and use somehow anyway let me know
what you think this book means in the
comments but of course this whole idea
of having an omniscient bird's-eye view
of Westeros is a direct setup for the
next person we see who has this same
exact view of the world brand yeah baby
bran is back but I think this awkward
reunion between bran and Sansa actually
parallels the awkward coming together of
John and Daenerys in both cases they're
two leaders on the same side but
ultimately talking past each other with
Sansa and Daenerys as the ambitious
leaders who want more influence while
bran and John are these frustrating
super-powered freaks from way up north
who don't even want power and a little
detail that I liked here notice how when
brand mentions that he's the three-eyed
Raven and looks over at the weirwood
tree in the distance we can hear a Raven
cough I need to be ready
all right moving on to old town and
after Sam brings yet another character
back from certain death on the show II
bro sold out its punishment make din
copies so now that Jorah is healed and
Jon knows about the dragonglass what do
we think stands next step is what is his
character's destiny I actually have an
interesting theory based on what's going
on in the scene so let's activate my
favorite segment in these Game of
Thrones breakdown Theory time
okay so ebro's makes it clear that these
manuscripts and Scrolls are old old old
they're falling apart filled with paper
mine which I didn't even know existed
but I am super tuna now so first
question what do we think Sam's gonna
find in these books we've got to find
something he always does really let's
ask ourselves what is the biggest
mystery left in Game of Thrones that's
right the White Walkers there is still
so much we don't know about them where
they're going what say once have they
turned code or into one of them
hopefully not I actually have a side
theory that White Walkers just want to
get revenge for being created by the
children of the forest and they're
headed to the weirwood Grove on the Isle
of faces in the gods eye and actually
you can hear more about this theory by
watching my biggest game of Thrones
mystery video
whatever those secrets about the White
Walkers are based on these books being
super old that no one has read them in
decades times Ian's fans going to
discover some lost knowledge about the
White Walkers in these Scrolls but I
also don't think it's going to be that
easy
this is george RR martin i don't think
he's going to let sam defeat the white
walkers but just opening the books and
following instructions like he did to
treat George greyscale so here's where
I'm going with this
I think system of the library is based
on a famous library from history the
Library of Alexandria in each of Egypt
guys that library burned it was believed
that all kinds of knowledge about the
ancient world was lost forever
so I predict that this Citadel library
will burn - may be Dragon Fire maybe
someone accidentally kicks over a wild
fire jar or maybe one of those astrolabe
lenses gets too hot and lights and arts
masters robes on fire I think it's going
to be Sam's destiny to carry the torch
of all of this knowledge history
remedies for greyscale dragonglass the
White Walkers and it's going to be on
him too
gradually pieced together all this
knowledge all from his own memory okay
let's move on to Tyrion explaining his
battle plan and Dragonstone
now the specifics of what exactly is
going on in the sequence confused a lot
of you guys actually did the first part
appearance plan with the unsullied
trying to climb the ladders really
happen or was it just a hypothetical
scenario that Tyrion was proposing not
to do I assume you already have your
answer here
but just know that we did put up a poll
and viewers are surprisingly split on
this kind of like the dress all over
again was Tyrion explaining two
separates black and blue alternate plans
or one complex white and gold plan now a
big part of the reason for this
confusion is because Tyrion is
explaining the plan as we see it happens
is a cool technique that filmmakers use
to condense a narrative you may remember
it used in Ocean's eleven but the
editing of the sequence seems to present
two ultimate strategies like it begins
materials voiceover on how outmatched
the unsullied are against Casterly Rock
defenses as we see grey worm leading the
seat then we cut immediately to the
unsullied getting taken down by
Lannister archers and for a second it
almost seems like that might be great
worm dead on the ground there but then
no Tyrion then explains an alternate
plan with grey worm leading a small
group into secret entrance taking out
the Lannisters and opening the gate so
does that mean that's the first sequence
that we saw it's just an imaginary
disaster scenario that never really
happened like it's super bad maybe but
if you look super closely at this when
grey worm sneaks into the guard tower
you can see Lannister troops rushing by
in the background as if they're
currently engaged in the siege of the
castle walls that we saw before and when
the unsullied rushed in you can see
those archers arrows in their shields
and then finally when we see the
unsullied fleet at the end of the
sequence it's in these same places was
in the first part of the sequence so
judging from all this evidence these are
both parts of the same real strategy
with unsullied dying out front to
distract the Lannisters from great worms
sneak attack from within I think it's
worth noting that this open-endedness is
kind of a director trademark for mark
mylow
remember last season he directed episode
7 and 8 with arya barely escaping the
weights of the faceless men and there
were some key inconsistencies there that
led to some obsessives online forming
all of these clues in
two interesting theories was that really
aria was there a fake aria is everyone
aria really I think that my Lud showed
both parts of Tyrians plan to reflect
Littlefinger's words from earlier period
is trying to think through every
possible eventuality
unfortunately it's the big one actually
predicted this might be Tyrians plan
considering this is all foreshadowed way
back in season two when i reached
manhood
I found the puppy in charge of all the
drains and systems in Casterly Rock
wasn't never flowed better and all the
[__] found its way to the sea and Tyrion
- explanation of why he created the
secret passage to smuggle in women is
itself another callback to season to
remember Tyrion used a similar secret
path to sneak out of the red key to
reach che in King's Landing and by the
way I like how grey worms infiltration
of Casterly Rock includes a stop by
Tyrians old undisturbed [__] bed and
then notice this line from Tyrion the
rocks technical soldiers does a good
friend of mine said give me 10 good men
and don't impregnate the [__] oh I
guess Tyrion has gone back to quoting
people other than himself and of course
this good friend was bran he actually
said this same line about the eerie way
back in season 1 give me 10 good men and
some climbing spikes I'll impregnate the
[__] now there's some interesting shot
composition going on here so let's take
a moment to discuss the creative imagery
used throughout this episode so here
right as Tyrion describes the unsullied
impregnating the Casterly Rock wall I
get this provocative overhead shot of
the unsullied rushing in and yeah they
angle those walls the central opening it
can't just be me right like I surely
Rock is getting pregnant ironically by
men who are incapable of getting anyone
pregnant now another instance of
creative imagery that I really liked
came in an earlier stage when Jon and
Tyrion are making their way up this
narrow walkway to Dragonstone notice how
the director uses this long complicated
tracking shot lining up the path as it
twists and turns so why did he do this
in this moment hearing and Jon are
literally discussing the long winding
road that each of them took to get to
this point and director Mark mylot is
dramatizing that by having the two of
them literally walk a long
Road and for the viewers who walked out
with them okay coming out of that
imagery analysis I do want to point out
that this shot of grey worm looking out
in fear at Euron's plate as it sinks
what's left of Daenerys is sleet and
traps them in I think this shot is meant
to parallel another miscalculation by
Tyrion last season when the slavers
fleet used similar fire bombs concede
Marines and it's going to be interesting
to see how Daenerys responds now that
Tyrion has effed up twice now if you're
curious why Daenerys is forces are now
oh and to build a mod actually have a
very interesting theory on how this is
happening okay moving on from Casterly
Rock to another new location that we
haven't really seen before Highgarden
so even though Jaime mentions it I just
want to clarify what exactly happened
here so Jaime used the same diversion
tactic against the unsullied army that
Robb Stark
used against him in the whispering wood
this was in the war of the five kings
which we saw in season two Robb allowed
Tywin distinct that they were going to
meet one-on-one battle at the green fork
but Robb tricked him by just sending a
small portion of his army meanwhile he
moved the main part of his army
somewhere far more valuable to strike
something far more vulnerable Jaime's
division and of course Jaime would
remember this whispering would battle
because it's where he got captured it
was the event that changed his life
forever so now he let the unsullied take
asily Rock which was expendable now as a
gold mines are depleted and he turned
his sights on something far more
valuable Highgarden now you'll notice
that Jamie has Randall and Dickon Tarly
Etta side so this isn't just Lannister
men Jaime has all of the Tyrells
bannermen to turn against vilena
and then after Jaime saxes it II notice
we get this quick shot of these golden
bars now I'm guessing these are the ones
that Cersei is probably hoping to use to
deliver on a promise to the iron bank
now in fact in the book Highgarden has a
rooftop garden maze it's a literal
Highgarden and as we saw Jaime marches
way to Alana's quarters I kind of hoped
that he would make a wrong turn and end
up in that big hedge maze and then when
Jamie finds Elena she says this line and
now the rains weep oh so yeah this is a
lyric from the Lannister victory song
the rains of castamere but you remember
tells a story of the last time the
made an entire house disappear which is
exactly what they're doing now by
killing off the final Tyrell Cersei
actually explained this history to
Alana's granddaughter Margaery in season
three and now we're seeing her deliver
on that breath do you know what house
rain is now gone gone a gentle word
she's seated but seriously making good
on our promises brings us back to this
idea of the Queen's justice so as we
come to a close here let's discuss the
title the episode that does the Queen's
justice mean so this phrase is a
reference to the King's justice
something that we've definitely heard in
Game of Thrones before the King's
justice refers to the duty of the Royal
executioner the guy who cuts off the
heads in the name of the king of course
in the north and Ned Stark's view this
should be done in the old way see who
passes the sentence should swing the
sword
either way the King's justice is Swift
and emotionally but what does this
episode say about the Queen's justice
well let's look at what Cersei does she
punishes a laureates and for killing her
daughter with a poison kids by doing the
same to her daughter and then she makes
her watch as her daughter gradually
brought and now she punishes alehna
Tyrell by having Jaime make her drink
poison wine and in case you missed this
like the punishment for ilaria and tyene
even though Cersei and Jaime don't yet
realize that this is also parallel to
the murder of another one of their
children Joffrey whom of course Olenna
poison and in both of these cases the
Queen's justice is the opposite of the
King's justice
the Queen's justice is heartfelt and
slow drawn-out and honestly it's created
the Queen's justice is poetic justice
it's reciprocal and I think it's fitting
that in both cases sir seeing youth
poison in the book poison is called a
woman's weapon so while the King Justice
uses a broadsword the Queen's justice
uses poison but later in the book Oberyn
Martell actually gave us a deeper
insight into poison she said any men who
calls a poison a woman's weapon is a
traitor to his fellow men poison is cold
calculating poison is the thought that
wakes you up in the morning and lulls
you to sleep at night you watch your
victim die a thousand times before you
ever offer him that fateful taste is a
man tastes so inferior to a one
means that we are to be denied such a
weapon so when you think of the Queen's
justice as a prison it actually gives
some new context to these closing images
with Elena and Janie
so remember ulema is nicknamed the queen
of thorns and I think in this moment the
Queen's justice also applies to this
Queen as well by revealing to Jaime that
she was the one who poisoned their son
Joffrey the Queen of thorns is
metaphorically poisoning the Lannisters
too because now Jaime has proof that
Tyrion was innocent but I'm sure Cersei
will never see Tyrion as anything more
than an enemy and I predict that this
conflict will grow strong has a toxic
corrosive disease to Queen Jaime and
Cersei and just like how the opening
images were a sign of doom bad news
coming in these closing images show bad
news going out as the Queen of thorns
and her dying moment delivers one last
dose of the Queen's ticket so what do
you think Jamie is going to do with the
lenez confession now and what did you
think about my theory involving Sam in
the library of the Citadel also what do
you make of Melisandre is lined to
various like do you think it's connected
to what Barrett's heard in the flames
and most importantly do you think John
and Danny are going to do it let me know
your thoughts and if you have any
further questions definitely tweet them
at us with the hashtag Westeros weekly
and Philip and mod might answer them in
the show you can hit me up at ei vas or
do rock stars at new rock stars and
share this video and subscribe to new
rock stars to see all of our Game of
Thrones content and if you haven't
already make sure to check out my
breakdown to the episodes 1 & 2 and keep
an eye out for my breakdown of next
episode these spoils of war and if
you're feeling generous you can
contribute to us on patreon and help us
make more of these videos thanks for
watching and see you next week bye
you